[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEENA DAVIS: When my daughter
was two, I started watching
little kids videos and programs
with her, and now I
had this incredible
spidey sense about
how women are portrayed.
And I was absolutely stunned to
see what I perceived to be
a huge dearth of female
characters in these
entertainments made for kids.
I decided I needed the
numbers if I was
going to have an impact.
Just my impression was not
having any impact on them, so
maybe if I got the numbers.
This is where my life took on
a whole new direction as a
datahead, like you all, and I
know what the ratio of male
and female characters
is in movies and TV.
Because about eight years ago,
I founded my Research
Institute on Gender in Media
because I wanted the answer to
one very specific question.
I wanted to know how many female
characters there were
in these entertainments that
were made for kids.
And so we now have conducted
the most extensive research
ever done on gender depictions
in media covering a 20-year
span, and the results
were stunning.
In family films, for every one
female character, there were
three male characters.
And of the female characters
that did exist, the majority
were either highly stereotyped
or hyper-sexualized.
Get this.
In G-rated animated movies, the
female characters wear the
same amount of sexually
revealing clothing as the
female characters in
R-rated movies.
So by now you might be thinking,
what the heck?
These numbers are appalling.
I didn't even know this.
What could be going on here?
But I want to assure you that,
through our research, we have
some positive news.
We found that if we add female
characters to these
entertainments at the rate that
we have been, we will
achieve parity in 700 years.
My organization is dedicated
to cutting that in half.
[LAUGHTER]
GEENA DAVIS: And we will
not stop until we
have achieved that.
So we have to ask ourselves,
what message are we sending to
boys and girls at a very
vulnerable age if the female
characters are one-dimensional,
sidelined,
stereotyped, hyper-sexualized,
or not even there at all?
Right?
We're saying that women and
girls are a little bit less
important to us than
men and boys.
So what do we do with
all of this?
What we do is take the research
directly, because I'm
in the industry, directly to the
studios, the networks, the
guilds, and present
it to them.
And they have had a consistent
reaction,
which is utter shock.
Their jaws are on the ground.
They had no idea that they were
leaving out that many
female characters.
And, in fact, they're like--
why would we do that?
We're making stuff for kids.
Why on earth would we do that?
The cure for seeing negative
images that impair girls'
self-esteem is to show better
images, to show empowering
images, to show women and girls
taking up half the space
in the world.
So the media itself can
be the cure for
the problem it created.
The most fabulous thing, of
course, that happened to us
recently was to receive one of
the Global Impact Awards,
which is incredibly, incredibly
meaningful to us,
not only in itself but because
of the extra attention that it
brings to the work
we're doing.
Because right now, we
do the research in
the traditional way.
It's very time consuming
and labor intensive.
We have like 60 grad students
watching all the films and TV
and taking the numbers down.
For a big study like the ones
we do, it can take almost a
year to get it completed.
But with this grant, it's going
to be aimed at creating
the software that will allow
us to do the research much
faster, much more precisely,
effectively, and, obviously,
cost effective.
We'll be able to, for the first
time, gather global data
because it won't cost us a
fortune to be able to do that.
We'll be able to research
in real time.
In other words, we can create
a new future through what
people see in the media.
If they can see it,
they can be it.
[APPLAUSE]